C'est très marrant!
L'homme....
... ce mammifère si particulier a toujours été avide de progrès
Pour améliorer son existence il s'est dépassé pour créer des inventions
qui ont changé le cours de sa propre histoire,
telle que le train à vapeurs, le téléphone ou les apéricubes
Mais comment a donc eu lieu l'invention de la télécommande?
C'est ce que nous allons vous raconter
dans cet épisode de l'histoire racontée
par des chaussettes
Alors, Eugène, est-ce que vous avez avancé sur le truc dont vous m'aviez parler la dernière fois?
Oui!
Ah, génial, montrez-moi ça, je suis impatient!
Je vais le chercher de ce pas .
OK, j'ai oublié ce que s'était le truc parce que j'avais plein de trucs
C'était les chaussures à hélices?
Non!
Les voitures à hélices?
Non.
Les fromages à hélices?
Non, ce n'était pas ça, c'était votre projet top secret, révolutionnaire, souvenez-vous?
Ah, mais bien sûr!
Vous êtes prêt?
Eh, plus prêt que ça, ça me ferait de la peine, Eugène!
Qu'est-ce que vous énerve le plus quand vous regardez la télé?
Ma femme!
D'accord, mais à part de votre femme?
Les communistes!
Hein, et aussi?
De devoir....
... vous... de devoir vous lever....
Pour?
- Pour? - Hein?
Pour changer de chaîne!
Ouais...
Bon, si je vous dit qu'il existe un objet qui vous permettra de changer les chaînes de télé sans se lever
Je vous dirais que c'est ma femme!
D'accord, humour des années cinquante, d'accord.
Mais là, votre femme n'est pas là.
Ma femme n'est pas là?
Votre femme n'est pas là.
Et elle est pas avec monsieur Stevens en train de faire des trucs bizarres?
Elle est pas avec monsieur Stevens en train de faire des trucs bizarres.
Et on n'est pas jeudi?
J'ai pas golf?
Et on n'est pas jeudi, vous n'avez pas golf.
Je vous écoute.
Si j'avais inventé cet objet
qui change de chaîne sans bouger de votre canapé,
qu'est-ce que vous me diriez?
Je vous dirait sorcellerie! Brûlons-le!
Non, si vous étiez pas catholique extrémiste?
Je dirais formidable! Eugène , montrez-moi ça!
Je frétille d'impatience!
Bougez pas, j'y retourne de ce pas.
C'était?
L'appareil à changer des chaînes!
Voilà!
Ah, cet inventeur... s'il n'existait pas, il faudrait l'inventer.
Ta-daa!
Oooh...
C'est donc ça?
Oui, exactement
Et j'ai appelé ça... écoutez!....
Le Flashmatique
Mmmm... mais, est-ce que c'est pas un peu trop...
Rectangle?
Le nom est pas bien?
La forme on peut la changer.
Comment ça marche?
Ah, ben, ça c'est simple.
On appui sur la chaîne de son choix et ça change automatiquement.
Donc si je veux voir la quatrième chaîne?
Ah, ben, facile!
Et si je veux voir la deux?
La trois?
La cinq?
La quatre?
La deux?
La une?
Si j'ai envie de la six?
Et la trois?
La cinq?
La quatre?
La trois?
La six?
La deux?
La une?
La trois?
La six?
La deux?
La une?
La quatre?
La six?
Et la deux?
La trois?
La quatre?
La deux?
La six?
La trois?
La deux?
La six?
La une?
La deux?
La trois?
La quatre?
La cinq?
Six!
Deux!
Un!
Trois!
Deux!
Un!
Six!
Quatre!
Deux! Six!
Un!
Deux!
Six! Un! Trois! Six! Quatre! Cinq! Trois! Quatre!  Cinq! Trois! Deux! Un! Un! Cinq! Cinq! Cinq!
Cinq! Cinq! Cinq! Deux! Un! Deux! Un! Deux! Un! Six! Trois! Trois!
Deux! Un! Six! Deux! Un! Un! Un! Un! Un! Un! Sept!
Aaaah!!!
Hahaha!
Ah, bien vu!
Eh, ben, oui, ça n'existait pas.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on en dit, Eugène?
On dit qu'il faut que j'invente un casque...
Et c'est ainsi qu'après plusieurs réajustements Eugène Polé inventa en 1955 la télécommande
et la commotion cérébrale
En tout cas d'après des chaussettes.
Mais dites-moi, Eugène, ce bidule, ça marche avec des ondes?
Oui
Est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu dangereux?
Non
C'est très marrant